Joelle has two after-school
jobs, babysitting and working
at her parents' grocery store.
Working at the grocery pays
her $12 an hour, and
babysitting pays her
$9.50 an hour.
Last week she worked
19 hours in total.
That looks like a
statement that
could lead to an equation.
Last week she worked
19 hours in total.
And she earned $56 more at the
grocery store than she did
babysitting.
That looks like another
statement
that could be an equation.
She earned $56 more at the
grocery store than she did
babysitting.
And then they ask us, how
many hours did she
work at each job?
So they want to know--
so let's define
some variables here.
Let's define time babysitting,
so t sub b, as equal to hours
babysitting.
And let's define t sub g as
hours at the grocery.
So they want us to figure out
what was t sub b and t sub g,
what were the hours of
babysitting and what were the
hours at the grocery?
Now, they tell us that she
worked 19 hours total.
So that blue statement says that
the sum of these two is
going to be 19.
So the time she worked
babysitting plus the time she
worked at the grocery store is
going to be equal to 19 hours.
Now the other statement.
This by itself obviously we
can't solve for these.
We need another constraint.
They said that she earned $56
more at the grocery store then
she did babysitting.
So let me define two more
variables here.
So this is the pay babysitting,
her total pay
babysitting.
And let's say P sub g
is equal to the pay
at the grocery store.
Now, what are these terms?
I mean, if we just look at this
second statement right
there, we'll just say, OK, the
pay at babysitting, she earned
$56 more at the grocery than
she did babysitting.
So this second statement tells
us that, well, I guess the
pay-- let me write it over
here-- the pay babysitting,
she earned $56 more at the
grocery than she did
babysitting.
So if we take babysitting and
add $56, that will get us to
how much she earned at
the grocery store.
That's what that second
statement is telling us. $56
more at the grocery
than babysitting.
So if you add these two,
you get the grocery.
Now, this still isn't cool.
We have one, two, three,
four unknowns
and only two equations.
That's not going to help us.
But what will help us we can
express these two variables in
terms of these two variables,
and then we have two equations
with two unknowns, so we can
solve them the way we've
solved all systems
of equations.
Now the other information they
give us is the rate, how much
she earned per hour.
Working at the grocery, she
makes $12 per hour.
Babysitting, she makes
$9.50 per hour.
So what is going to be
her pay babysitting?
Let me write this over here.
Her pay babysitting-- I'll do
it in this color-- her pay
babysitting is going to
be equal to the time
babysitting, right?
The time babysitting times how
much she gets paid per hour.
The time babysitting is how many
hours, times how much she
gets paid per hour.
It tells us right there.
She gets paid $9.50 per
hour babysitting.
So times $9.50.
That is what her pay
babysitting is.
And then, same argument, what's
her pay working at the
grocery store?
Her total pay working at
the grocery store.
Her pay at the grocery is going
to be equal to the time
at the grocery times the rate
that she gets paid at the
grocery. $12 per hour.
So times $12 per hour.
And this hopefully
is intuitive.
If I'm making $12 per hour and
I work for, I don't know, 3
hours, I'm going to make $36.
I would just multiply
these two.
If I worked 2 hours at $9.50,
I'm going to make $19.
That's all this is.
A total pay.
So now we can take these two
expressions-- we could take
this expression and this
expression-- and substitute it
back into that equation right
there, and then we'll have an
equation that's only in terms
of the time babysitting and
the time at the grocery store.
So let's do that.
So this first term right here,
her total pay babysitting,
that is this expression
right there.
So let me write it right here.
So $9.50 times the
time babysitting.
So I'll just write 9.5 times
time babysitting-- that's this
term right here-- plus 56 is
equal to the pay that she got
at the grocery, which is 12
times the time at the grocery.
And now we need to solve for
both of these variables.
We have two equations
and two unknowns.
This is just straightforward
algebra at this point.
So let's do it.
So the easiest way to do this
might just be to do straight
up substitution cause we have
all these crazy numbers here.
Let's just solve for the time at
the babysitting in terms of
the time at the grocery.
So if you take this top
equation-- let me write it
over here-- so the time
babysitting plus the time at
the grocery is equal to 19.
If you subtract the time at the
grocery from both sides,
you get the time babysitting
is equal to-- these cancel
out-- 19 minus the time
at the grocery.
So we solved for the time
babysitting in terms of the
time at the grocery.
So everywhere we see the time
babysitting, we can substitute
it with this expression
right here.
That's what t sub b is.
That is what the time
babysitting is.
So let's do that.
So this equation becomes 9.5
times the time babysitting,
which we just figured out from
this top equation is 19 minus
the time at the grocery, plus
56, is equal to 12 times the
time at the grocery.
And now we just have to solve
for the time at the grocery.
So 9.5 times 19.
That's a little bit of hairy.
Let me just do it over here, on
the right side right here.
So if I have 19 times 9.5.
5 times 9 is 45.
1 times 5 is 5, plus 4, is 9.
And then we have a 0 here.
9 times 9 is 81.
9 times 1 is 9, plus 8, is 17.
So 5 plus 0 is 5.
9 plus 1 is 10.
1 plus 7 is 8.
You just have a 1 there, and you
have one number behind the
decimal point.
So it's 180.5.
So 9.5 times 19 is 180.5 minus
9.5 times the time at the
grocery, plus 56, is
equal to 12 times
the time at the grocery.
Now what's 180.5 plus 56?
So 180 plus 50-- let's add just
those two terms-- 180.5
plus 56, just to simplify it.
180 plus 50 would be 230.
So this'll be 236.5 minus 9.5
times the time at the grocery,
is equal to 12 times the
time at the grocery.
Now we can add the time at the
grocery to both sides of this
equation, or the 9.5.
So let's do that.
Plus 9.5 times the time at the
grocery is equal-- or plus 9.5
times time at the grocery.
Just adding it to both sides
of that equation.
And we are left with-- the
left-hand side, that cancels
out-- we just have 236.5 is
equal to, 12 plus 9 is 21, so
this is going to be 21.5.
It's equal to 21.5 times the
time she spent at the grocery.
So now we can just divide both
sides of this equation by
21.5, and we've figured
out how long she
spent at the grocery.
Let's do that.
Divide both sides by 21.5.
So that cancels out.
The time she spent at the
grocery is going to be equal
to that thing.
And let's see what that is.
We get 21.5 goes into 236.5.
Let's multiply both of
these numbers by 10.
So this is the same thing
as 215 going into 2,365.
The decimal goes right there.
215 goes into 236 one time.
1 times 215 is 215.
And then we can subtract-- let
me scroll down more-- this
problem is hairier than
I thought it would be.
So 36 minus 15 is 21.
So 21-- bring down the 5-- and
lucky for us that's pretty
straightforward.
215 goes into 215 one time.
1 times 215 is 215.
Subtract.
You get no remainder.
So the time at the grocery
store is 11, or 11 hours.
Now we can go and substitute
back to figure out her time
babysitting.
We know that the time
babysitting is equal to 19
minus the time at the grocery.
In this case, it's
19 minus 11.
We just figured that out.
19 minus 11 is 8.
So her time babysitting, she
spent 8 hours babysitting.
And we are done.
They both add up to 19, and you
could make sure that they
also verify.
That also works out for
the second equation.